well I think most artists would you say
I mean we had this long conversation off
camera about right-brain left-brain
whole brain I found a fascinating thank
you um wouldn't you say the mark of the
most artists was right brain oh yeah
most artists Mets dubbed the creative
brain but actually there is a creative
brain and left to but it's dubbed a
creative brain and that's the uh you
know that it just flows you know the
personality work emotions they wear
their heart on their sleeves you know
and so the perp it just kind of fits
with entertainers any kind of artist but
do you think someone can be a
right-brain person like let's take n
stein let's say could he go and tweet
about his book on twitter and and and
and he'd probably get somebody to do it
for him like I do okay see I don't do it
they do all of that um well mainly
because a I don't have time i'm a
professor also but be i don't want to do
it and they know how to do it better
than I do you know they know what to do
and they make me look good and I like
that part I have a hard time with me
making me look good I there's a fine
line for me I can do this because it's
just my personality but I have a hard
time with the other promotion yeah sure
I need a promoter and I think that's
what you know it's a risk on their part
because it can the person deliver oh I
can deliver but not everybody can sew
some others are more reserved more quiet
or you know if you would peg me and no
one would peg me as a professor because
you kind of put a professor in a mold
you know and yeah
professor I read dissertations for a
living that's how I need to have a
creative side
you